so you guys have been talking about this
for a long time and Harvard is actually
starting to create lab-grown meat and
taking inspiration from a cotton candy
machine oh so they're trying to make the
sounds the meat tastes fibrous by doing
the little layers that cotton candy
machines make when it's whirls around
edges swirling a steak they're currently
reverse engineering how me is created
it's gonna be a DNA to be tough for us
for a while before we get involved in
but the time our kids or our age will
have it for sure yeah [ __ ] you hundred
percent yeah we're not gonna have five
predicted farms will be eight something
will look at it look what we did to cows
you think I I think if it's easy enough
to grow in a lab why would you eat
something without a central nervous
system that didn't feel pain I mean
right now it's just technology in price
that's it that's it
then you're gonna have those Psychopaths
that want to slit the throat oh sure and
in pigs
well you'll have it makes natural ists
will be able to find those Psychopaths
you'll have heirloom meat which means I
want to go back to the way my forebears
cuz my bio on the table but then
there'll be a lot of science that says
we're making the best meat actually
because it's omega-3 fatty acids better
for your body but doesn't think about
how they can be only God didn't plan it
well though the cows will die off though
and we want to eat as much grazing land
cuz cows don't live that long and
they'll just die off and or they'll be
you know used for other purposes oh
leather
we stayed or well we got leather leather
you know whatever matter yeah you know
will they'll fish you make leather - all
right you may have meat leathers these
oh yeah oh yeah
although I'll tell you what you still
can't really replicate good leather in a
lab you can't replicate good fur you
can't it's it's just got a special
something as you rub your there's
nothing like
that's right human skin is amazing as
well everyone I didn't think really gif
he gave me when I get you the best
blanket of all time but I thought I'd
look at it in every time you got it [ __ ]
a lot of beavers had to die fits really
nice lob even gave me a beaver blanket
yeah I went through it like count like I
measured the hell I looked online how
big and how big this probably 24 beavers
up 36 beavers guys thank you Dan I don't
be good I don't need that bad juju hey
bro I don't give a [ __ ] wrap your kid in
that [ __ ] that's something it's fashion
comfy man and and Ivy it is so comfy
yeah beavers are trapped and used all
the time so I was like alright I'll make
a blanket out of it and I eat the meat
then everyone every evening every 6bv
for those slaughters it's beaver member
that died in the trap slower we call
that the critter right I [ __ ] ate
that meat I don't know if world is
happening I got a freezer full of beaver
meat okay anybody they're another story
yeah what else you get beavers far the
best I've ever eaten no I swear to God
you eat their tail no you can't eat
their tail but you can but it's a it's a
very solid fat a second again you can't
eat their tail but you can can why it's
super chewy and hard to Justin Theroux
with you when he were feeling this
Justin wrote this whole have you ever
had beaver tail gum when no no it's just
chewy web Steve really happy you know
dude Steve Rinella made me and Rogen
some some beaver and it was it's I'm so
sad about everything is the best meat
I've ever had in my life really I'll eat
all the beaver I'll eat all the beaver
and yes you can eat the tail look people
eat it tell me not any [ __ ] up man
yeah I'll only kill something having to
eat then I'll wear its fur so many other
things being killed besides the cute
little bee here's my problem with beaver
here's my problem of the eating beaver
and here's my problem with beaver
blankets now that I know
forgive me everybody you got to trap
them I don't like that you have to trap
them because then I stray thinking I
want to shoot them so they die quickly
anything you trap that die slowly I
ain't touch that's a problem for me
but I don't know for a fact that the
Beavers the beautiful until I have your
blanket another hand hey buddy hold
angled if we see the world never kills
they were killed humanely and they were
killed
systematically back tracker in the
justin throat Amos they were not trapped
and they were not tortured they were
killed like that just grab their stupid
little face isn't right over them it's a
way to do it just put like in a utopia
first yeah just you know like the
beavers is like I put their hair right
in the equivalent of a pencil sharp like
no you just have a dam made for them and
it's like look what you made
I've hunted and killed enough deer to
know that there's I don't like doing it
I really don't I love the meat but I and
I think I've dropped every deer I've
ever shot right away because I'm
terrified
I got they call me dead I not for me
that's how you got you and roll you guys
asked me to go hunting I'd probably
shoot that dance just start crying you
well you I don't believe you do you
think that but once you because you're
competitive as [ __ ] and once you add
that deer in your sight bro and we're
hungry and we've been looking for three
days I [ __ ] promise you cuz you want
to eat that and I hope but check this
out
Snickers back pocket not when you're not
when you're dying for me cuz I'm
thinking about fine
sniggers can't live on Snickers alone
you can't imagine that dehydrated
mountain food we have all you want is to
shoot a [ __ ] deer that I made it
right there I am wrong maybe Libya maybe
bring something with you they do I
brought I brought some turkey not the
same you got to have fresh deer fresh
blood you can eat it right there and
we're all do Bambi first blood yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]